Metro Police say that a convicted
murderer who escaped the southern desert
Correctional Facility Friday is in
custody at this hour our 8 news now
investigators first reporting that law
enforcement Tracked Down 42-year-old
Porfirio Duarte Herrera in downtown Las
Vegas now these are brand new photos of
the suspect released by Metro tonight
thanks for joining us here at 11 o'clock
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus
Ryan Matthey is live from where he was
taken into custody on Eastern right near
Owens Ryan
yeah Brian Denise this is a five days
long run that's ended here just outside
of bus depot in downtown Las Vegas you
can see the scene has died died down
quite a bit since we came on scene about
30 minutes ago when we arrived it was
full of cop cars there were different
Witnesses or people being interviewed by
police now again we're just near the
intersection of Owens Avenue and North
Eastern Avenue it's over 30 miles from
the prison that this man 42 year old
Duarte Herrera is accused of escaping
from on Friday police say they were
tipped off about a man who fit the
description of this man around 9 30
today when they came down to check they
confirmed the identity of the man and
subsequently took him into custody now
this is also just a few hours after the
U.S Marshal Service raised their reward
money for information and the recapture
of this man it was additionally five
thousand dollars it has now been raised
to thirty thousand dollars this bus shop
we have also looked online it does
service to out of the country areas it
does include Tijuana Mexico we have not
confirmed if they've had any services to
that area in this hour right now but
again we are on scene of the uh
accusation that the man who escaped this
prison uh is now being captured here in
downtown Las Vegas this is outside of
bus depot the uh the bus depot that does
service to out of the country areas what
I'm going to come back into the frame
right now we're just now coming on scene
and just getting a bit more information
we're still unclear about who exactly
tipped them off and now what does this
man face after escaping from this prison
for nearly a full week we're gonna stay
on scene for the hours ahead to keep you
guys updated with what we know so far
but for now reporting in downtown Las
Vegas Ryan Matthey 8 News Now